ABCs of AI I is for image recognition a
type of artificial intelligence that
allows computers to identify objects in
images or video it's used in a variety
of applications including image search
self-driving cars security scenarios
Medical Imaging QR codes product search
and so much more remember our ABCs of AI
video F is for facial recognition facial
recognition is a type of image
recognition looking to try it out
yourself head over to cloud.google.com
Vision or check out the link in our
description to try out Google's Cloud
Vision API where you can test it out
yourself right on the page pretty cool
huh you'll also find tutorials quick
starts use case diagrams and even more
resources to help you get started what
topics do you want to learn more about
on the next episode of